llegó el momento hablar de la revista de
prensa para ello ya está conmigo el
estudio rosa pérez más de un rosa félix
lunes bienvenida muy buen día por
supuesto vamos a empezar esta entrega de
revista de prensa con los papeles de
pandora con cinco medios de la región
primero empecemos con el país y américa
latina' titula quienes aparecen que es
una sociedad offshore papeles de pandora
en américa latina' rosa buenos días raúl
exactamente como comentas no podíamos
empezar esta sección de otra forma y
hemos querido fijarnos exactamente en
medios de la región que hayan
participado de esta investigación porque
tal y como lo cuenta el país esta es la
mayor colaboración periodística de la
historia han participado prácticamente
600 periodistas de más de 150 medios de
comunicación en distintos entre ellos
pues los que vamos a ver a lo largo de
esta sección y un poco del país de
américa latina hace un abc de lo que es
exactamente esta investigación llamada
papeles de pandora nos recuerda que son
más de 12 millones de documentos
proporcionados filtrados por 12 de 14
despachos
especializados en la creación de
entidades financieras y pues son papeles
investigaciones que repercuten a más de
300 políticos y funcionarios en el cargo
actualmente ex mandatarios no y también
nos recuerda que es exactamente un
paraíso fiscal pues recordemos son
territorios que tienen pues una política
de impuestos una política tributaria muy
laxa o muy baja para precisamente atraer
inversores internacionales y son a
territorios que proveen un alto nivel de
anonimato en todos los registros no de
las sociedades mercantiles y te voy a
dar dos datos es raúl que nos ofrece el
país y es que un 10 por ciento del pib a
nivel mundial se encuentra en las
sociedades offshore pero es que
recordemos la sociedad social como tal
no es ilegal lo que es ilegal es
esconder el capital o la riqueza a las
autoridades tributarias competentes y
otra cuestión para seguir con lo que es
américa latina y es que el continente
según de tax justice proyect que es una
entidad basada en brasil pierde cerca de
46 mil millones de dólares anuales en
impuestos no tributarios seguimos
haciendo la ronda por los periódicos
américa latina' vamos con zipper en
chile titula familias piñera y del ano
sellaron millonaria compraventa de
minera
dominga en islas vírgenes británicas
eso es a raúl este periódico bueno más
que un periódico es una fundación de
periodismo de periodismo de
investigación de chile que ha
participado en esta investigación y que
señala evidentemente la implicación de
piñera y este es uno de los principales
titulares que encontramos en la región
del actual presidente de chile pues que
en 2010 vendió parte de sus acciones
vendió todas sus acciones de este
proyecto minero a una figura que es a
nivel personal la política y empresarial
muy
próxima a este mandatario que es carlos
alberto délano pero es que lo curioso
precisamente es que pues esta
transacción se completaba solamente si
ya no había cambios en la regulación
medioambiental que afectaran al proyecto
y este proyecto y esta regulación
un día ya de piñera porque ya se
encontraba justo empezando su primer
mandato así es rosa y vamos ahora con el
universo en ecuador guillermo lazo se
deshizo de entidades offshore antes de
ser candidato eso es el universo este
medio de ecuador que también participa
de este consorcio y precisamente pues
guillermo lasso lo que lo que tenía es
pues muchas inversiones en panamá no que
se considera también pues un paraíso
fiscal y precisamente de cuenta este
episodio dedicado al actual presidente
de ecuador que cuando empezó a tener
aspiraciones presidenciales pues
trasladó estas inversiones a eeuu porque
precisamente en 2017 cuando esto ocurrió
el ex presidente pues entró en vigor una
ley que fue diseñada por el ex
presidente correa que impedía a los
candidatos presidenciales ser
beneficiarios de sociedades offshore
ahora si rozábamos con las imágenes que
estábamos viendo anteriormente la nación
argentina y el espectador en colombia
empezamos una nación porque aparece una
sociedad no declarada de mariano macri
en un paraíso fiscal así titula la
nación eso es vamos a repasar los rápido
si quieres básicamente la nació en este
periódico argentino como comentamos
todos los que mostramos han participado
de este consorcio que han sacado los
papeles de pandora pues el hijo menor
del ex presidente argentino mauricio
macri pues aparece en esta investigación
como beneficiario de una de estas
empresas offshore en este caso en belice
y en el espectador pues también destaca
el actual director de la dian la
dirección de impuestos y aduanas de
colombia y pues también para terminar
raúl con este con esta gran
investigación que recordemos que está
reportada en prácticamente todos los
medios a día de hoy solamente recordar
que en colombia también está también
figura el ex presidente césar gaviria
exacto y andrés pastrana así es rosa
vamos rápidamente con alemania porque me
hizo llorar el discurso de merkel sobre
los alemanes sobre los alemanes del este
porque rosa pues mira para poder seguir
un poco con la mirada puesta en alemania
precisamente ayer la todavía canciller
ha en funciones angela merkel dio el
discurso con
pues la reunificación de alemania de
1990 y precisamente este periódico
destaca como en este discurso la
cancillera fue capaz de mostrar una
parte de su figura que hasta el momento
pues había ocultado en estos 16 años de
mandato y es precisamente lo que le ha
supuesto pues el hecho de ser la primera
canciller también proveniente del este a
nivel de prejuicios de los políticos del
está así es rosa gracias por estos
titulares de la prensa nos vemos mañana
con más vamos ahora con nuestro primer
invitado el día